ma prima di cominciare con il blog di
oggi ragazzi cose a random cosa caro
saluta la gente i capi ma cos'è
io non c'ho la patente lui sia la strada
ma è un figo sonagli che vi salutiamo
amici grazie di essere tornati a fare la
spesa per me grazie poi però è sempre
detto e sempre levarvi dal cazzo mi date
sempre più fastidio corsa su con quel
cazzo di scardole io sto portando le
chiavi di casa veloci quel momento in
quindi tutti gli amici al caso tuo per
passare una giornata diversa finalmente
non davanti ai computer finalmente non
davanti videogames e la cristo santo
bene dei sotto consiglio di stefano a
mangiare qua che fugge 6 dirmelo che
aveva per turisti hanno imparato a
cucinare
[Musica]
non so perché ho fatto questa cosa però
ci avevo di video sul telefono
abbastanza divertente ci ha voluti
ficcare in mezzo ma che cazzo se frega
passiamo ad un argomento un po più serio
che poi ragazzi i miei blog durano
all'incirca otto dieci minuti più o meno
a vi siete mai chiesti come sarebbe un
blog se lo stringessi proprio all'osso
dicendo vi sono le cose principali
durerebbe tv secondi facciamolo sto
esperimento te la senti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo nuovo video sono fa vj
ed oggi siano nuovo la prima di
cominciare come al solito partiamo dalla
fama della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da michela che
ha fatto questa fanatec stupenda volevo
dirvi che la 11 parto per los angeles
che vado alle 3 volevo dirvi anche che
l'ultima volta che sono andato in
america ho comprato un sacco di roba che
ancora non vi ho fatto vedere tra i
quali pure questa che ci devo fare un
video sopra assolutamente non a coloro
vedrete ho montato questo nuovo ombrello
superfigo che ti fa fare la luce bella
che se lo spegne e brutto e se invece
non lo spegne e figo sta per uscire
outlast due quindi tra poco solo nella
merda e miei ragazzi questo era tutto ci
vediamo nel prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]
uscirebbero tipo così questa stronzata è
nata perché qualcuno mi ha scritto nei
commenti favi ma perché ci metti dieci
minuti per dire le cose perché non dice
tutto in un minuto va bene il problema è
che se lo faccio in un minuto non si
capisce un cazzo perché non spiego un
cazzo e viene una merda
eccola la tua risposta della minkia e
nient ragazzi li ho appena fatto un
riassunto di quello che andrò a dire nel
blog però adesso lo dico sul serio visto
che ci siamo prima di cominciare ragazzi
di partire con la farà della settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da
manuela che ha fatto la fa nat sua oni
più bella che abbia mai visto
stanno dicendo che oggi sabato 11 sono
partito per los angeles perché c'è l'e3
di los angeles che si tiene ogni anno
sommato anche l'anno scorso e farò un
video come al solito di tutto quello che
succede state tranquilli che ho già
preparato tutti i video per coprire i
giorni in cui non ci saranno tornerò il
18 e vi ho fatto vedere anche sta cosa
prima perché vi spiegano da chi non la
conoscesse la tavola ouija che serve per
evocare gli spiriti demoniaci
non ho proprio intenzione di farlo
adesso che dopo piam aereo magari lo
faccio al ritorno faccio mega blog di
tutte le cose che ho comprato e ho preso
un sacco di robert
possono notare la bellezza di questo
zaino superfici compreso robe che non
potete neanche immaginare tipo gli
occhiali di harry potter o roba tipo che
sono le caramelle tutti i gusti più non
sempre di tipo cioè non avete idea di
quanta merda solo a farvi vedere
comprerò altra roba a los angeles e vi
farò vedere anche altra roba per ora
guidato la tavola luisa elli micale nome
d'ora rifinire il blog per andarla a
mettere a posto ha paura che mi salti
addosso tanto non vi ho detto che c'è un
ombrello in casa aperto
ve lo spiego ragazzi perché ancora non
l'ho fatto vedere non è che l'ombrello
degli illuminati o di gesù che fa la
luce qualche giorno fa mi sono reso
conto di essere uno you tube e mi sono
reso conto che potevo anche migliorare
un pochettino la qualità dei video
e allora ho comprato questa luce di
posizione credo si chiami così non ne
sono sicuro pa più [ __ ] la luce perché
senza di questa sarebbe così
praticamente uguale e passando alla news
bella che adorate sicuramente tutti
tranne per chi ci agli esami che i
ragazzi miei è finita la scuola di
inizia l'estate tre mesi di vacanza da
paura un sole che spacca le pietre prova
costume andiamo a vedere come questa
fantastica estate tutti insieme estate
e la prova costume
allora forse ho sbagliato utilizzare
questa cosa in questo modo
dovevo fare così dall'inizio però il
problema scuola un'altra estate arriverà
e porca [ __ ] vacca quanta pioggia che
cadrà ragazzi voi non avete idea di
quanto fottutamente ci ho messo per
montare sta merda che non riesco a
montare manco i lego e per fare questa
cosa che voi vedete quanto ciò
fottutamente messo non potete capire
allora io quest'estate vi faccio un
altro mega spoiler incredibile andrò al
tomorrowland brachino lo conosce una fee
è una festa una roba è un evento dove
praticamente partecipano un sacco di dj
tra i quali anche i binari che sono dei
dj italiani e durante la settimana ho
saputo scrollando la pagina di facebook
che ai binari erano ospiti a radio
deejay come ho letto questa cosa si è
risvegliato il fanboy che è in me
nonostante diluviasse sono uscito di
casa ho iniziato a correre per strada
col diluvio universale per andare ad
incontrare vinai a radio deejay che lo
dico e non ho mai fatto sta cosa nella
mia vita ma sto correndo in mezzo alla
pioggia con bastardo tale signora perché
e va beh come un ragazzino lega 10 10
anni in realtà applica quanto piove e
distante ancora un chilometro buon'ora
di dj da qua non so come farò ad
arrivarci sponsor della macchina la vj
venduto vado
ok non credo di fare mai più una roba
del genere però avere quindi ragazzini
che possono si vedevano le ascelle sotto
i peli passando da un altro argomento
visto che a me l'avete chiesto anche
questi giorni e oggi ve lo posso dire se
core che devo smetterla di gesticolare
non mi fa benissimo che hanno chiesto
ragazzi di essere la voce di un
personaggio secondario nel film di
ratchet e clank quindi anche se solo per
poche battute perché poi sono una decina
in croce di button è che potevo doppiare
un personaggio principale non essendo un
doppiatore mi hanno fatto fare un ruolo
secondario ma comunque superfigo e fino
ragazzi uscirà il 29 giugno
giulio il 29 giugno no un nuovo [ __ ]
mese uscirà il 29 giugno e rimarrà nelle
sale fino al 3 luglio quindi per pochi
giorni chi vuole andare a vederlo solo
quei giorni già disponibili sono e io
farò la voce di un personaggino piccolo
minuscolo che non si caga mai nessuno
che si chiama zed che questo è un
robottino bello però che adesso visto
che la mia vocina del cazzo tutti solo
caleranno e stata un'esperienza stupenda
già visto il film è bellissimo ma
veramente di un figo che non avete da
perché poi io vabbè adoro ratchet e
clank ma questo già lo sapete perché ho
già detto stiamo facendo un implicito
ratchet e clank
nel film c'è lo stesso tipo di comicità
che c'è anche nel videogioco c'è proprio
una roba è bellissimo per gli
appassionati di ratchet e clank sarà una
chicca pazzesca anche per chi non l'ha
mai visto sarà epico vi faccio vedere
questo pezzettino mi hanno dato la
possibilità di usarlo quindi lo metto in
cui mi faccio sentire un pezzettino del
film dove c'è la mia voce le schiave
prima che cominciate a farmi delle
domande è importante che sapete che io
sono fedele al mio datore di lavoro
io doppio zeb che un
un robottino simpaticissimo ea degli
sbalzi d'umore incredibili che
il che mi rappresenta un sacco possiamo
scambiarci posti ora
io sarò lì davanti mondo è veramente
però anche essere presenti in pochi
istanti di film per me è tutto
c'è veramente è tutto sono veramente
contentissimo di aver avuto questa
possibilità davvero passando ad un altro
discorso visto che ultimamente mi state
tartassando i gioielli ma prima lo sai
che è uscita la demo di outlast 2
molti di voi pensano che noi non la
faccia perché mica go addosso il che
potrebbe essere anche vero ma non è
questo il caso in realtà è uscita la
demo di outlast 2 e l'hanno giocata in
pochissimi youtuber in tutto il mondo
perché la demo di auto as2 è uscita ma
non è pubblica c'è nel senso l'hanno
data solo proprio agli lavata più di pai
e non posso farci un gameplay sopra
perché non esiste la temono la potete
scaricare quindi finché non la posso
scaricare non c'è corso fi gameplay
neanche della demo comunque outlast 2
gioco completo uscirà quest'autunno è lo
farò subito ava ragazzi con probabile
episodio io direi che posso veramente
andare a los angeles e incontrare paris
hilton nel mentre che non ci sarò al mio
canale sarà gestito da paris hilton
oppure dallo spirito che uscirà dalla
tavola ouija io spero che visto vi sia
piaciuto cosi e se vi è piaciuta un
certo un commento è un mi piace alla
famiglia manda a casa visto dimenticato
sono scese di che faccia effetto fatemi
solo sapere se al mio ritorno da los
angeles volete che io faccia il video su
una tavola ouija fatemelo sapere si o no
ma tanto vi conosco ormai che cazzo
stadi come se vi è piaciuto sono un
commento è un mi piace anche la pagina
di facebook che vede in video trattante
descrizione se non siete city si aggiri
ci mettiamo al prossimo video e ragazzi